so a lot of stuff been going on with the
DC movies largely just um confirmations
of cancellations which I know has some
people rather frustrated especially
around Henry Cavill who he was gearing
up to come back and be Superman again
that is now not happening that's been
confirmed Wonder Woman 3 is no longer
going to happen uh and all sorts of
things just seem to be getting scrapped
it does look like they are still Manning
to release the Flash and Aquaman too but
that's probably only because those films
are already shot and while I uh can be
sympathetic to those who really wanted
some more continuations of these things
this doesn't really come as a surprise
because with James Gunn taking over as
the creative lead on this if he wants to
do his own thing he was either going to
have to deliberately
um work with what was already existing
or he was gonna have to do a clean slate
trying to do anything in between it was
just going to hamper his ability to do
his own thing because there were so many
expectations attached to this universe
that just aren't going to happen now I'm
gonna do a fuller video on this in the
new year but for now I just wanted you
to note that I know